what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so as we get into superior spider-man
again we're kind of doing this little
bit of a prelude here but really with
suicide run it's really necessary and
that's kind of the cool thing about this
is that suicide run it gives us an idea
of what Doctor Octopus is going to do in
the body of Peter Parker and that was
really what was necessary about this
story just because of the fact that when
you know Dan Slott was kind of leading
up to this whole superior spider-man
thing that nobody really knew that it
was coming it was just dance walk kind
of saying what he always says
oh this story's going to change things
forever and this story's going to change
the landscape of the spider-man mythos
and nothing's ever going to be the same
and it was cool to see it for what it
was I mean it was interesting to kind of
you know see how it all played out but
the very idea here was that we were
basically going to see what we were what
direction the stories would end up going
and you know of course the idea that
Doctor Octopus and Peter Parker have
presumably switched bodies forever and
that was really the indication that was
left here at the tail end of this story
now keep him on in the last video we had
talked about how with their body
switched the mind of Peter Parker was
basically in the body of Doctor Octopus
who was moments away from dying I mean
he was right around the corner from
death just knocking on his door and so
really Doc Ock is just kind of
considered himself home free or we're
gonna go ahead and call him superior
spider-man to go ahead and keep the keep
it easy to understand but superior
spider-man they kind of considered
himself home free you know in the idea
that he was like well I mean our bodies
are swaps the body of Doctor Octopus is
going to die Peter Parker is going to
die inside that body and that will be it
not only that Peters biggest concern was
that superior spider-man would go around
and basically start doing things like
reforming a relationship with Mary Jane
Watson and that was kind of the crazy
thing because fans thought that was
going to happen and in fact we get that
little bit of a teaser here one of the
first things we see is superior
spider-man spending time with Mary Jane
and the idea - the two of them are
basically going to get together or at
least it seems like it's going to happen
oh she says look is this a date the two
of us being here together is this what I
think it is and Peter you know superiors
part of man's response is yes it's
exactly what you think it is we're
getting back together now from here
superior spider-man is basically alerted
to the fact that Doctor Octopus has
broken out of his cell and that was
really the huge thing because of course
superior spider-man was always on a
lookout to see whether or not Peter
Parker was able to find a way to escape
his confines and that's exactly what
happened the issue with this is that you
know the body of Doctor Octopus again
was moments from dying and so Peter
Parker does exactly what he
to do and basically just kind of jerks
the body awake this Creole kind of
bringing it back to life but in this
three minute period between the time
that he dies and the time that he comes
back he basically ends up visiting his
hometown and what he ends up seeing are
a lot of these individuals who had died
we end up seeing people like Gwen Stacy
captain Stacy the father of what we end
up seeing these various individuals who
have played significant roles in the
life of Peter Parker but all of whom
have effectively passed on know more so
than that then Uncle Ben now this is one
of the greatest moments in the entirety
of the Spartan and run I always always
considered it is when you look at Uncle
Ben Uncle Ben is probably the most
important character in the life of Peter
Parker despite the fact that he's dead
and the reason why is because when Peter
first developed the powers of spider-man
when he was first bitten by a
radioactive spider he did what every
teenager does he got carried away he
made some foolish decisions you know he
kind of let his powers get the better of
him he got revenge on you know bullies
are giving him a hard time he did what
any of us would have done but in this
path he lost sight of the fact that his
actions can also lead to inaction if he
doesn't act what he needs to someone
around him could basically lose their
life and that's what happened with Uncle
Ben and for years and years and years
and years Peter Parker was guilt ridden
he always sat around and said if only I
had done something okhla Ben would still
have done a lot but because of this for
this kid Peter this kind of last bit to
basically say goodbye this last little
instant the more let's just kind of walk
away you know to be 12 by Uncle Ben I'm
as proud of you as I ever could be
you've become every ounce of the hero
that I believe you that you could be
you've done proud you've done me proud
with your actions as a hero and that's
really what Peter needed that was the
motivation he needed to keep going on so
what the story does is it basically just
kind of transitions to you know Peter in
the body of Doctor Octopus making his
escape to Leia to an underground hideout
but it's also this idea that they're
initially caught up to by Carly remember
Carly is the ex-girlfriend of Peter
Parker but works in the works in the
police department and so the initial
idea here for Peter is hey hardly knows
who I am
Carly can help me to solve this problem
now there's the issue with this this is
where Dan Slott really begins to hit
home with the idea of the you know the
whole body swapping thing is that to
Carly's eyes this is Doctor Octopus she
was in see Peter Parker she sees Doc Ock
she sees a bad guy she sees a villain
now for Peter Parker tries to say hey
look I can prove that it's me you and
Mary Jane Watson are the
only do people who know my identity
Carly this kind of blows off and says
well doctor octopus's figured out what's
going on at Peter Parker and the fight
ensues and of course she's incapacitated
pretty quickly remember Carly is just a
regular human being no extraordinary
abilities or anything like that but in
light of this superior spider-man
basically begins rounding up the friends
and family of Peter Parker and that's
why this is cool is because under the
guise of spider-man operating as Peter
Parker superior spider-man basically
says hey look we need to keep you guys
safe right you know me Doctor Octopus
has escaped from the RAF he's got
moments left to live he's one of
spider-man's most formidable enemies he
knows you guys associate with me we need
to find a way to keep you safe and in
the guise of keeping them safe he
basically turns them into hostages and
that's kind of the cool thing here is
because now he has lies on his side and
that's one of the biggest weaknesses or
even one of the biggest strengths of
Peter Parker depending on how you look
at it is that he will not kill unless he
absolutely has to that was one of the
huge significant moments in the renew
your vows story during singer wars when
he basically allowed venom to die in
fact he really kind of killed venom by
really doing nothing like he's kind of
letting The Scindia burn alive letting
you know letting venom essentially die
his inaction just kind of allowed those
events to happen but in Peter Parker's
mind it was what needed to be done it
was basically saving his family and so
what is up happening here is that when
Peters superior spider-man come face to
face it's kind of a slight bit of an
exchange here in there of course Peters
basically in this bunker out in the
middle of nowhere you know in this
here's you know a trash heap that you
know of course belong to Doctor Octopus
but the idea here is superior spider-man
says look if you want to play that game
that's the game that we can play you
know if you want to play this idea of
well you know me and I know you so on
and so forth disappear spider-man
basically gives the location of doctor
octopus's hideout sending them directly
to Peter Parker now to be honest with
you guys the superior spider-man is
really terrified here and the reason why
is because Doc Ock has really had to
admit on a multitude of occasions that
Peter Parker is extremely intelligent
there I say as intelligent if not more
intelligent than Doctor Octopus and
because of this what is up happening
here is superior spider-man is terrified
of the idea that Peter will come back
and reclaim his body and so he's
literally just throwing every single
thing he can at him especially when
you're spider-man you can use the tools
of the police on your side you can use
the Avengers on your side you basically
have every single hero at your disposal
when you can go to them and say Doctor
Octopus is trying to kill my
and family you have to help me they will
go to the ends of the earth in order to
make sure the Peter Parker and the ones
that he loves are kept safe now from
here this is when we get into Dan Slott
really toying with the spider-man fan
base when we have Mary Jane Watson going
to meet with superior spider-man yet now
of course this is really just kind of
you know a couple people bumping heads
we're both extremely stubborn of course
you know Mary Jane's like look I think
keep hassling you or you can just come
and answer the door but when the two of
them start talking
what is up happening is Mary Jane just
confesses her love for Peter Parker she
says look I absolutely love you like I
don't know if where we're going to be
anything I don't know this is ever going
anywhere I don't know if or fooling
ourselves who cares but I love you and
what is up happening is the two of them
share a kiss now for those individuals
who were reading spider-man and who had
been around since the events of one more
day it was almost like oh my god is it
going to have it was that hope will they
won't they think are they going to get
together are they not going to get
together it's dance logon to finally
come around to bringing them back
together now of course we know that's
not the case and in fact Dan Slott said
on Twitter repeatedly he's never going
to allow Mary Jane Watson he's never
going to you know we're going to see
Mary Jane Watson and Peter Parker
getting back together just strictly by
editorial mandate Marvel editorial does
not want that to happen Marvel does not
want those two characters getting
together they want to leave the past in
the past despite the fact that a lot of
people really want to see it take place
apparently that's not going to happen at
all instead the closest we're ever going
to see to Mary Jane Watson and Peter
Parker being a couple again is in the
ongoing renew your vows story coming out
of Marvel right now but what is up
happening here is Doctor Octopus
essentially traces down you know
superior spider-man so because of the
fact the superior spider-man when he
took the different you know friends and
family of Peter Parker to keep them safe
he basically thrown them in a room in
Avengers mansion but what is up
happening here is a pretty
straightforward fight I mean it's really
just kind of Dan Slott wrapping up a lot
of loose ends but between Peter Parker
and Doctor Octopus this is a this is
insane fight it's a fight in the extreme
and the reason why is because Peters
literally fighting for his life if he
ends up losing this battle he's going to
lose his identity Doctor Octopus will go
forward in the body of Peter Parker
presumably forever and there will be no
way for Peter to regain his life
everything he's been fighting for it
will have been lost now the cool thing
is that Peter is extremely intelligent
and he always has a back-up plan in this
instance his backup plan was to grab one
of those little octobots that allowed
the mind swapping process in the first
place and reverse that on Doc Ock
meaning that Theo this this Bob would
allow them to switch their bodies back
to the way they're supposed to be the
issue here is it again Doctor Octopus is
also extremely intelligent and so
because of that he planned for this
possible eventualities and that's one of
the reasons why Doctor Octopus is so
formidable as a villain when it comes to
battling Peter Parker Doctor Octopus
usually always plans two three four five
steps ahead and so while I wouldn't go
as far as to say that he always defeats
Peter Parker he would present a
challenge for most anybody because he's
considered so many different variables
and taken almost all those variables
into account and so because of this one
of them happening is that this bot
cannot switch the bodies back Peter
Parker is effectively stuck in the body
of Doctor Octopus Doctor Octopus is in
the body of Peter Parker and this is
when the story seriously begins to
become something special what is up
happening here is that Doctor Octopus is
sort of forced to relive not only the
great moments of Peter Parker's life but
the terrible moments of Peter Parker's
life he begins to really understand what
it means to be spider-man it's not just
traipsing around getting the girl having
a great time fighting on the Avengers
there's a lot of responsibility that
goes into it because in Peter Parker's
mind every single time he went out into
a battle every time he went on to a
fight it was always fighting for the
people that he cared about it was
fighting for his loved ones who was
fighting for his friends it was fighting
for his family the responsibility that
came along with those things
Doctor Octopus begins to realize the
weight that is now on his shoulders with
Peter Parker effectively dying in the
body of Doctor Octopus Peter says look
it's your responsibility now you have
that power if you're going to become me
then you have to fight for the people
who deserve health you have to make sure
that the friends and family that I know
you have to make sure that the people
that I care about the people that
believe that you're me that they are
safe and so what this does is it
basically steps forward with this idea
that you know Doctor Octopus in the body
of Peter Parker is effectively going to
leave his criminal life behind he's
essentially going to become a good guy
and that's what makes this so great is
because this sets the stage for him
turning over a new leaf
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
people look to superior spider-man and
said it really is just a genuinely good
story in their minds Peter Parker will
always be
spider-man it'll always be Peter Parker
it will always be a return to that
familiarity a return to that status quo
but when we get these small little
stories we get to see what it looks like
when somebody else is in the body of
Peter Parker is Doctor Octopus
legitimately a better spider-man than
Peter Parker is is he more intelligent
is he more capable is he able to do
greater things and we'll see that happen
we'll see the formation of what will
become Parker Industries going into
all-new elephant novel we will see you
know the early formation of that company
here in superior spider-man we'll see
the introduction of Anna Marconi and
ongoing character and all-new
all-different amazing spider-man we will
see her in this story a lot of the
things that you guys are going to come
and notice with regards to the whole
all-new all-different spider-man
landscape we're going to see a lot of
those things growing here in superior
spider-man and then expanding outward
from there going into the main
spider-man spider-man series as well as
the eventual reboot with all-new
all-different marvel but again this is
really just kind of designed to show us
what direction things are going to go in
and to be quite honest I think superior
spider-man's probably one of the
greatest father man stories ever told
I love the direction that it goes and I
love the idea of Doctor Octopus trying
to be a good guy using his intelligence
as well as the fact that he's just kind
of a jerk but if you guys are new here
to come and explain make sure you guys
fit the sub button to become four out of
the rockwork if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you